tonight three students arrested in ccsd
after attacks on teachers in different
schools just last week the district
announcing a zero tolerance policy for
violence today's incident is happening
in different parts of the valley sasha
loftis is here with what some believe is
causing the trouble sasha denise and
brian many of the teachers i spoke with
today say they're scared to go to work
they hope to see something change and
want the district to understand they are
dealing with this every day
three attacks on three different ccsd
campuses in one day it's very worrisome
that this is happening students were
arrested at foothill high school grant
sawyer middle school and palo verde high
school wednesday for assault or battery
on teachers and staff educator ryan
fremols says stories like this are
becoming all too common i can guarantee
you right now the teachers are screaming
at the tv
the district does not listen to us and
psychiatrist dr sid karuna believes
mental health needs to be addressed in
more ways than one teachers who are at
the front line they are the victims he
says it's important to address the
trauma many teachers have experienced
and know that some aren't ok they are
experiencing an assault a trauma he
added that kids may not show signs of
anxiety or depression like adults and in
some cases violence is a cry for help
when they are depressed they are less
likely to be sad they are more likely to
be irritable and angry and aggressive dr
karuna says it's important to catch
warning signs at home
and for mult hopes ccsd leaders take
action to keep everyone safe the powder
keg is about to explode and
we need the district to
care
dr karuna attributed a lot of mental
health issues to the isolation and the
stress of the covet 19 pandemic he said
it's more important than ever to
encourage students and teachers to ask
for help if they need it denise